The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LIZ SPELKE: I want
to talk about--
you asked about development
of knowledge within infancy--
and I want to talk
about one case
where we've seen an interesting
developmental change.
One that I don't think we
really fully understand.
I'm sure we don't
fully understand it.
I'm not sure we
understand it at all.
But it seems to be there.
And it has to do with
effects of both, maybe,
inertial properties
of object motion
and also effects of
gravity on object motion.
Let me just tell you
the result first.
These are studies that
were done by In-Kyeong Kim
a long time ago.
But recently enough,
that video was
part of our toolkit, which
wasn't always the case,
and involved showing
babies videotapes of events
in which an object
held by a hand
was placed on an inclined plane,
released, and started to move.
And in one study,
babies either saw
a plane that was inclined
downward, the hand released it,
and it rolled downward with
the natural acceleration,
or the plane was inclined
upward, the hand released it,
and it rolled
upward, decelerating.
OK?
We studied this
in adults as well,
and for adults, adults
reported that it
looked like this hand
set the ball in motion.
In fact, to control
the motion better,
there was a sling shot apparatus
that actually set it in motion.
But it underwent what looked
like a natural deceleration
from the point at which the hand
released it and as it rose up.
Half the babies were
bored with this event,
and half were bored with that.
And then, at test, we
switched the direction
of the orientation
of the ramp so
that if babies had been seeing
something move downward, now
they were seeing events
in which it moved upward.
And in one of those
two events, it
underwent the
natural acceleration
that adults would
expect, which is to say,
a change in the motion that the
infants had previously seen.
So these guys saw this
thing rolling downward
and accelerating.
And here in the
natural event, they're
seeing something that's
being propelled upward,
and it's decelerating.
OK?
In this event, they saw
the same motion pattern
that they saw before, so if
they saw speeding up here,
contrary to effects of gravity
on object motion.
OK.
So the question
was, if the babies
were sensitive to
effects of gravity,
they should look longer
when the thing accelerates,
you know, speeds up
as it's moving upward
than they do when it slows
down as it's moving upward.
On the other hand, if they're
not sensitive to gravity,
and they're just
representing these events
as speeding up or
slowing down, they
might show the opposite pattern.
OK?
And that's actually what
we found in both conditions
of that study.
At five months of age, babies
showed the pattern opposite
to what adults would
expect, as if they thought
an object that speeds
up in the beginning
is going to continue speeding up
irrespective of the orientation
of that plane, with
respect to gravity, OK?
So failure at five months,
success at seven months.
At seven months,
we get a reversal,
and they flip in their
looking times here.
Well, we thought,
maybe the 5-month-olds
will succeed at a simpler task.
Suppose we start
out just showing
them a flat surface
and constant speed,
so we're not engendering
any expectation
that this object is going
to speed up over time
or slow down over time.
They're just seeing
a constant motion,
and then they get
tested with events
in which the object is
placed either at the top
or at the bottom of this ramp.
It's released, and it
speeds up in both cases.
In that case, will they view
this motion as more natural
and look longer at that one?
Or, you might ask, would they
show the opposite pattern
[AUDIO OUT] if these events
are difficult for them,
show the opposite pattern?
What they actually
showed was absolutely
no expectation, the
5-month-olds, in that case.
OK?
They seemed utterly
uncommitted as to whether it
was more natural for the
thing to be moving downward
than to be moving
upward after seeing
it move on this flat surface.
Then, at seven months, kids
responded as adults would.
Then we thought, maybe there's
just a problem with video.
Maybe kids don't understand
that vertical in a video
corresponds to vertical
in the real world.
So we just ran a
control experiment
to see if that was true,
by familiarizing kids
with downward motion
in the real world
and then presenting those
same two test events.
And now they showed the
pattern that adults would show.
That's not showing any knowledge
here, it's just saying,
yeah, they can distinguish
downward from upward,
and they can relate
real events to video.
But they don't seem to have any
prior expectation that objects
will move downward when they're
rolling on an inclined plane.
And all these things seem to
develop between five and seven
months, which I
think provides us
with an interesting window for
asking what's developing here.
One possibility is
what's developing
is something very local.
But I don't think
so, because there's
another change also occurring
between five and seven
months in what looks like
a very similar situation.
These are experiments that
were conducted in Renée
Baillargeon's lab, where she did
these very simple studies where
you'd have a single
object in an array,
and then a hand would come
in holding another object
and place it on that array.
And in that top study, she
compares infants' reactions
when the hand places the object
on top of the box, releases it,
and it stays there,
versus places
the object on the side
of the box, releases it,
and it stays there.
OK?
Now, if you're a
3-month-old infant,
you are equally happy
with those two events.
You do not look
differentially at them.
But by five months, infants do.
They look longer when the object
seems to be stably supported
by the side of the box, than
when it's stably supported
by the top of the box.
But then she goes on
and asks, do infants
make distinctions among
objects that are stably
supported from below?
As, by the way, they were in all
those studies with the rolling
on the ramps, right?
Do they make the
kind of distinctions
that we would make
based on the mass
of the object, the physical
force on the object,
and so forth?
And to get at that,
she did a second study
where she has a
box, and she either
places it in the middle
of the top box or way
off to the side where we
would expect it to fall, OK,
not to be stably supported.
7-month-olds get that
right, 5-month-olds do not.
So across these
different situations,
it looks like we have
this developmental change
in what infants know.
I mean, I think these studies
raise a lot of questions
that they don't answer
about what infants are
learning over this time period.
I'm excited about
that because I think
they also give us a method for
addressing those questions.
OK.
And Tomer has been working
on chasing that [AUDIO OUT],,
which would be great.
OK.
So I've been asked
already by a bunch of you,
what happens at the very
beginning of visual experience?
I do have some slides on that.
I do want us to take
a break, but let me
go through them very quickly.
There's been a little bit
done with newborn infants,
and where they've been
studied under conditions where
we are confident that they're
able to see what they're
being presented with.
It looks as if some of these--
there's evidence for these
abilities in newborns,
but most of the
things I told you
about have not been
tested in newborn infants
and would be really
hard to test in them.
But fortunately, humans
aren't the only animals
that have to be able to
find the objects in a scene
and track them through time.
Other animals do that as well.
And many animals seem to
succeed at representing objects
under the conditions
where infants succeed.
The big problem we
have with animal models
is that in many
cases, the animals
are way more competent
than the infants.
And they succeed in cases
where infants would fail.
OK?
But at least where
they succeed where
infants succeed, we
can ask, what would
happen with controlled rearing?
And can we at least
get an existence proof
that in a mechanism of the
sort, that the abilities
that we see in infants
can be performed
by some nervous system
on first encounters
with visible objects
and types of events
that it's now being
asked to reason about?
So this has been done with
controlled reared experiments.
I'm going to talk
about just a few,
show you the results of
just a few experiments
that were done on chicks.
Chicks are being
used a lot lately
because they grow up pretty
quickly, they're easy to raise,
and they show this innate
behavior toward objects.
That gives us a nice
indicator, which
is in some ways a little bit
like preferential looking,
though opposite in sign.
They imprint if you show
them an object repeatedly,
and a chick has been
isolated, so there's
no other chicks or hens
around in its environment.
The object is the only
moving object they see.
They will imprint to it,
treat it like another--
behave as they would with
their mom, were she there.
And in particular, if
you then take the chick
and put them in a
novel environment
where they're a
little bit stressed,
they will tend to
approach that object.
So this has the same
logic as looking longer
at a novel thing.
You have a selective
approach to a familiar thing,
and you can now run, on chicks,
the kinds of experiments that
have been run on human infants.
So here is one
imprinted chick to a--
these are experiments
that have actually
been done a while ago, in
some case they're much more
recent, imprint a
chick to a triangle,
and then present them with
a triangle whose center is
missing, either
because it's occluded
or because there's a gap there.
Who's mom in this case?
The one with the occluded
center, not the one
with the gap at the center.
OK?
Consistent with
findings with infants
in one way, these chicks
are perceiving occlusion,
but they're doing
better than the infants.
This works when the objects
move behind the occluder.
If you move objects
behind the occluder,
you get all the same
kind of motion effects
that I was talking
about with infants.
But it also works if the
object is stationary.
So the chicks are better than
the infants in that case.
What about object permanence?
Here's a task that
babies can't solve
until they're 12 months old--
well, eight months in this
case, 12 months in this case--
that chicks solved
the first time
they're presented with an
imprinted object that moves out
of you.
I should have said that
on the previous slide.
The chicks never saw occlusion
until the imprinting test.
Here, they're imprinted to mom
on the first two days of life,
but there's no other
surfaces in the environment,
so they never see her
occluded by another surface.
Maybe they see her occluded by
their own wing or something,
but not by other objects
in the environment.
OK.
There's two screens there.
A chick is restrained
in a Plexiglas box
and sees mom disappear
behind one of the screens.
They will go and search
behind that screen for her.
Only at 12 months
do human infants
solve the following problem.
Mom has disappeared
behind and been
found behind this screen
five times in a row.
Now she goes there,
where will chicks search?
A baby, until 12 months, will
search behind the first place
where she was hidden, where
they found her in the past.
A chick is more like
a 12-month-old baby,
shows the more mature pattern.
He goes where mom actually is.
AUDIENCE: Are these
images or actual moms?
LIZ SPELKE: These
are actual moms.
This is imprinting
to either a ping pong
ball in some of these studies
or a cylinder in other studies,
dangles on a wire during
the imprinting period
so you can see that it moves.
It moves here, and
it kind of dangles
and moves behind one
screen or another screen.
And then the chick is
released, and the question
is where will the chick go?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are
these other chicks?
LIZ SPELKE: I think
they imprint them
for two days post hatching.
So they're hatched
in an incubator.
In the killer study I'm
going to tell you about,
the incubator's in the dark.
They spend two days in--
I think they spend a
day in the dark getting
used to just walking around.
And then starts the
visual experience,
and it's controlled,
so no occlusion.
But you do see this one object
that they get to imprint you,
and then they later
go toward the object.
OK?
So an existence proof that
such a capacity could exist
doesn't tell us that it does
exist in a young infant,
but it could.
Here's the one that
was done recently,
that's my favorite study
in this series on solidity.
OK, here's a study where the
chick is hatched in the dark
and spends most of the day
for the first three days
of its life in the dark.
But during a certain
period each day,
it's put in a Plexiglas
box with black walls,
a black floor, black ceiling.
And through the Plexiglas,
there is a single object that
dangles that they imprint to.
OK?
Now, they can't
touch the object,
so they never get evidence
whether this object is solid
or not.
They can't peck at it, right?
They can peck, but
they can only peck
at this black surface
that they can't see
or at this transparent surface
that they also can't see.
So they might learn there are
objects in the environment,
but they're not going to have
any visual characteristics
like this guy does.
OK?
All right.
So then after this experience,
the chick stays in this box,
and in that box, sees
a series of events
involving this object.
In the first set of
experiments, the object
moves behind one screen
and then is revealed there,
or moves behind the other screen
and then is revealed there.
In this particular
study, the chick
does not get to go out
to get to that object.
They did a series of studies
before this one where they did,
but in this case
study, they don't.
Then they see a second set
of events where all they see
is mom starts moving toward the
space between the two screens.
Then there, a screen
comes down, so they
can't see what happens next.
And then when the
screen comes up,
she is no longer
visible, but she then
emerges behind either
one screen or the other,
basically teaching
the chicks, in effect,
mom can go behind each
of these two screens,
OK, either of these two screens.
And then comes
the critical test.
In the critical test, mom starts
moving toward the midpoint
of the two screens.
The screen comes down, and
when the screen-- sorry,
the big occluder--
vision is blocked,
and then when that
curtain raises again
and the two screens
are again visible,
they've been rotated backward.
And across a series of studies,
they vary the size of mom
and the degree of
rotation of the screen.
And the question is, will
the chick go to the side
where the screen's rotation is
consistent with a solid object?
And they do.
I want to argue from that that
knowledge of solidity-- well,
knowledge in some
sense-- representations
that accord with solidity
is innate in chicks.
And what I mean by
innate is simply
that it's present and
functional on first encounters
with objects that
exhibit that property.
This chick has not
had the opportunity
to peck at these
objects, or observe
them bumping into each
other, or anything like that.
And the first time they see
this degree of rotation,
they make inferences that are
consistent with that principle.
This doesn't tell us
that human infants do it.
To be convinced
of that, I'd want
to see evidence for this
ability in an animal that's
a much better model for
human object cognition.
Or I'd want to see more
evidence from the chicks
to convince me that,
actually, the chick is
a really good model of
human object cognition.
But I do think it
should encourage
us to start thinking about how
nervous systems could be wired
to exhibit this property in the
absence of specific learning
and experiences with it.
Here are some questions that
we could talk about in the Q&A
later.
I can give you the
one-liner on it.
On the issue of
compositionality,
the question is, do babies
have a laundry list of rules
about how objects
are going to behave,
or are they building some
kind of unitary model
of the world that accords with
certain general properties?
I think the evidence,
starting at least
at eight months of age--
lower than that, we don't know--
but starting at that
age, I think the evidence
favors the second possibility.
It comes primarily from
these beautiful studies
that were conducted by
Susan Carey and her students
and collaborators where
they presented infants
with an event that
violated cohesion.
So this could be a sand pile
that's poured onto a stage,
or a cookie that's
broken into two pieces
before those pieces
are put in boxes,
or a block that falls apart
when it's hit by another block.
And then, she asks, having
seen that this object violated
this property, do they
expect it to accord
with the other properties?
And the answer is
no, they don't.
OK?
So for example, if
you've seen, there's--
in that causality study where
an object moves behind a screen,
and then another
thing starts to move--
if instead of starting
to move, it falls apart--
it violates cohesion,
falls apart--
infants no longer expect
the first object to hit it.
OK?
Maybe it fell apart
on its own, OK?
They don't assume
that it's going
to behave like an object
in other respects.
They also don't assume that sand
piles will move continuously,
that they won't pass
through surfaces,
that a cookie that is
broken in two-- if you have
two cookies in one box and one
cookie in the other, the babies
crawl to the two.
But if you have one large
cookie, and you break it in two
and put it in one box, they're
neutral between those two
options.
OK?
So it looks like the system is
acting like an interconnected
whole.
What the babies learn about one
aspect of an object's behavior
bears on the inferences they
make about other aspects
of its behavior.
The final thing I want
to end with that I think
makes this point
is very recent work
that was conducted
by Lisa Feigenson--
that I think Laura Schulz
may talk about as well.
Josh mentioned it last Friday,
but didn't really describe it--
that I think suggests that at
least at the end of infancy--
and again, we don't know
what's happening earlier--
infants' understanding
of objects
isn't only forming an
interconnected whole,
but it centers on abstract
notions about the causes
of object motions.
So these are studies that
picked up on some old findings
from a variety of labs.
Here's one that
Baillargeon had worked on,
and I did studies on it
as well, where infants
see an object that's moving in
an array that has two barriers,
but the barriers are
mostly hidden by a screen,
and the object moves
so that it's fully
hidden by the screen.
The question is, where
will it come to rest?
Looking time studies
say babies expect
it to come to rest at the
first barrier in its path.
They look longer if they find
it when the screen is raised
behind the second barrier, as if
it passed through that surface
in its path, a
solidity violation.
Here's another study that
Baillargeon and others
have studied showing that
by three months of age,
infants expect objects to fall
in the absence of support.
If you push a
truck along a block
so that it stops, but under
conditions where it stops, when
it gets to the end of the block
or continues off the block
and doesn't fall, infants look
longer in the latter case.
And what Feigenson
asked is, suppose
we don't let look infants
look as long as they want.
Suppose we limit
their looking time
to just a couple of seconds,
so they've looked equally
at these two outcomes.
What is their internal state?
Are they just bewildered in
the case where the object did
something impossible?
Or are they seeking
to understand
what's happening in the world?
Is this a learning
signal for them?
So she did two experiments--
actually, more than two--
but asked two questions
with experiments.
One question was,
suppose after showing
this event, or this event,
or this, or this one,
after showing an event where
an object behaves naturally
versus apparently
unnaturally, you now
teach infants in effect, try
to teach infants in effect
some new property of the object.
So you pick the object
up and squeak it.
And the question
is, do the babies
learn that the object
makes that sound?
And what she finds is that
the infants learn much more
consistently about the object
whose previous behavior was
unpredicted than about the
object whose previous behavior
was predictable.
OK.
I think this is both good news
and bad news about all the
looking time methods I've
been telling you about.
The good news is
looking time really
does seem, when you let babies
look for as long as they want,
it really does look like
that's tracking what they're
seeking to learn about their
exploration and learning.
The bad news is that when
you restrict looking time
to just a very short
amount of time,
there are many, many things
that could be going on.
They could be attending
a lot, or they
could be attending a little.
It's a very crude measure
that's not telling us that.
But here's a richer measure
suggesting differential
learning in these two cases.
The other study, I
think, is even cooler.
In the other studies, after
showing infants a violation
event, she handed
infants the object,
and allowed them to
explore it, and looked
to see what they would do.
And what she found is that they
do different things depending
on the nature of violation.
So when there was a
solidity violation,
they take the object, and
they bang it on the tray
in front of them.
OK?
In the case of a
support violation,
they take the object,
and they release it.
OK?
So if they're specifically
oriented at 11 months,
and we don't know
what happened earlier,
they're specifically oriented
to expected properties
of the object that could be
relevant to understanding
the apparent violation
that they saw.
To summarize, it
looks like there
is a system that is growing
over the course of infancy,
as it's clear from
all the questions
that we can continue to discuss.
There's a lot we don't
know about this system.
But at no point
in development do
infants seem to
be perceiving just
a two-dimensional, disorganized
world of sensory experiences.
At no point do they seem
oriented to events going on
in the visual field as
opposed to the real world
when you test them
in these situations
where you're asking
them questions
about properties of the world.
They seem to be oriented to
properties of the world itself.
And to start out
already, as early
as we can test them,
in a few cases,
like the center-occluded
objects, that means newborns.
To start out already
with a system which,
although it's radically
different from ours,
we see that most of the
things that we know about,
most of the information we can
get about objects from a scene,
they do not get.
Nevertheless, we're seeing
core skeletal abilities
that we continue to
use throughout life
and that seem to be present to
serve as a basis for learning.
There have been lots of
studies in which infants
have been presented with people
or other self-propelled objects
that have used the same logic
as the studies for looking
at naive physics to get
at something like naive
psychology in infancy, what
they know about object motion.
Most of them are
on babies that are
older than the babies
from the object studies.
Those studies ran mostly up
to about four months of age.
These studies are
starting later than that,
but they give us
a starting point.
And here's one slide that
tries to capture just
about everything that I
think we know about what 6-
to 12-month-old infants,
how they represent agents.
First of all, they represent
people's actions on objects
as directed to goals.
So this is a basic study
that was conducted--
a whole series of
studies, one of many--
conducted by Amanda
Woodward, who
was the advisor for
Jessica Sommerville, who
will be here giving a talk
on Thursday afternoon.
They're very simple studies
in which she presents babies
with two objects side
by side, and then they
see a hand reach out and grasp
one of those two objects.
And the question is, how do
babies represent that action?
Do they represent it as a motion
to a position on the left,
or do they represent
it as an action
with the goal of
obtaining the ball?
And to distinguish
those two possibilities,
she then reverses the
positions of the two objects,
presents the hand
in alternation,
taking a new trajectory
to the old object
versus the old trajectory
to a new object.
And the babies look
longer when the hand goes
to the new object,
suggesting not
that they can't
represent trajectories,
but that they care more about--
bigger news is the agent's goal.
When the goal changes,
that's a bigger change
for the infant than
when the motion simply
changes to a new path
and a new endpoint.
That's at as young as
five months of age.
Then there's been studies
showing that infants' goal
attribution depends on what is
visible from the perspective
of the agent.
So if two objects are present,
and the agent consistently
reaches for one of them,
babies in some sense,
in some poorly-understood
sense, represent that agent
as having a preference
for the object
that they've chosen to go
for over the other object.
But if the object they
didn't go for is occluded,
and there's no evidence
that that agent ever saw it,
they don't make that
preference, inference.
OK?
Third, infants represent
agents as acting efficiently.
And this is true whenever
they're given evidence
for self-propulsion,
whether the object that's
moving in a
self-propelled manner
has the features
of an agent or not.
So with these classic
studies by Gergely
and his collaborators that
continue to the present day,
but started, now, I
guess 20 years ago,
they present infants
with two balls
that engage in self-propelled
motion and even
a little kind of interaction.
And then one of the balls
jumps over a barrier
to get to the other ball.
And across a series of
familiarization trials,
the barrier varies in height.
The jump is appropriately
adapted to it.
And the question
is, what do infants
infer this agent will do when
the barrier is taken away?
Will it engage in one of its
familiar patterns of motion,
or will it engage in a
new pattern of motion
that's more efficient
to get to the object?
And the finding is, they
expect that new motion
and look longer at
the more superficially
familiar but inefficient
indirect action.
Here are my favorite studies.
This is one that Shimon talked
about yesterday afternoon.
He talked about one
version of this.
The original study was
conducted by Sabina Pauen,
and Rebecca Saxe and Susan
Carey did interesting extensions
on it.
It uses the simplest
imaginable method.
They present babies first
with two objects, stationary,
side by side, one
with animate features,
a face and sort of a fuzzy
body, tail-like body,
the other, an inanimate ball.
They're both stationary,
and the objects
were chosen to be about
equally interesting.
The babies look about
half the time at each one.
Then, they see a series of
events in which these two
objects are stuck together
and undergo this very
irregular pattern of motion.
This was actually some
kind of parlor trick
toy that was sold for a while.
They got them started
on this study.
There's a mechanism inside the
ball that's actually propelling
the two objects around.
But the question is,
which of these two objects
does the baby attribute
the motion to?
And to find that out, they
subsequently separated the two
objects again, and ask again,
which one will the infant look
at more?
And after seeing this
motion, the infant
looks more at the one that
has the animate features.
Although both objects
underwent the same motion,
they attribute that motion to
this guy, not the other guy.
It follows then that
they're perceiving
this-- they're representing this
guy as causing the other guy's
motion.
Right?
The other guy is not seen
as causing its own motion.
The motion is being
caused by this guy.
This is at seven months of age.
Now, even stronger evidence
that infants infer causal agents
come from these
beautiful studies
that Rebecca Saxe, and Susan
Carey, and Josh Tenenbaum
conducted 10 years ago
now, that went back
to this efficient
situation where
you see an object
efficiently going over
barriers of variable
heights to get
to a new position on the stage.
The one thing they
added is that the object
is manifestly inanimate.
It's a beanbag.
And the kid had a chance to play
with it before the study began.
They can feel that this
is not an animate object.
So if this isn't
an animate object,
and infants are actively
trying to explain
the motions of
objects that they see,
they're going to need
another kind of explanation.
And what Saxe, Tenenbaum,
and Carey showed
is that infants
infer that there is
an agent, off-screen, on
this side of the screen, that
set that object in motion.
And they show that by
their relative looking time
to an event where a hand comes
in on that side of the screen,
which is consistent with that
causal attribution, versus
it comes in on the other side,
which is inconsistent with it.
And really, a
pretty manipulation.
If in fact babies are making
causal attributions here,
then you ought to be
able to screen them off.
If you make a simple
change to the method,
you show evidence that actually,
this object is animate.
If it is animate, then you don't
need to infer another cause.
So they ran that study
as well and showed
that when you change
from an inanimate object
to an animate one, you no
longer get this effect.
OK?
So it really looks like they're
seeking to explain these events
and doing so in accord
with the principle
that agents can cause not
only their own motion,
but also can make changes
in the world, cause motions
and other changes in objects.
And a final study
that shows this,
I told you that if a truck goes
behind a screen toward a box,
and then the box
subsequently collapses,
babies do not infer that
the truck hit the box.
OK?
Collapsing takes this
outside the domain
of physical reasoning
for those young babies.
OK?
But suppose instead of a
truck going behind that-- this
is work by Susan Carey as well.
Sorry, I should have put it
on here, Muentener and Carey.
If instead of a truck, a
hand goes behind that screen,
now they infer that the
hand did contact the object.
OK?
So hands can make things
move, and they not only
can make things
move, they can make
things do all sorts of
things that objects otherwise
won't do, like fall apart, OK?
All right.
So one problem, as I said,
with all these studies
is that they're all older
infants, many of them
much older infants like 8- and
10-month-olds, just about all
of them 6 months old or older.
And when you test
younger infants,
you get failures on
some of these tasks.
So these goal attribution tasks
work with 5-month-old infants,
but they fail with
3-month-old infants.
3-month-old infants
seem uncommitted as
to where this hand is
going to go once the two
objects exchange locations.
And that raises the question--
to me, the most
interesting question--
what kinds of representations
of agents, if any,
does a younger infant
have before they're
able to act on the
world by manipulating
things, which starts
around five months of age?
And tell you just quickly, two
kinds of studies that I think
get at this--
imperfectly, but
they're getting there.
One is, again, going
back to studies
of controlled reared animals.
Chicks, again, in particular.
There have been
imprinting studies
done where chicks are
raised in the dark,
and all they get to
see are video screens
in which you get two objects
engaging in this simple causal
billiard ball type event.
One object starts to move,
contacts a second object,
and at the point of
contact, it stops moving,
and the other object
starts to move.
OK?
And they see that repeatedly.
And now, OK, I told you that if
chicks are raised in isolation,
but there's a moving object
there, they'll imprint to it.
I was treating the
imprinting object
as just an example of an object.
But of course, the
imprinting object is mom,
and she's an agent.
So it should be a self-propelled
object, really, right?
So given a choice
between these two,
do they selectively imprint
to one over the other?
And the finding is that they do.
The two objects have
different features,
I think, different colors,
maybe different shapes as well.
If you now present one of
them at one end of their cage
and the other at the
other end, they'll
go to object A over object
B as if they saw that
as the object that set the
other object in motion.
But now you could ask, is that
because they see A as causal,
as causing its own motion?
Or is it for other superficial
reasons like A moved first,
or A was moving at the
time of the collision,
and B was stationary?
So they tested for all of
these things one by one,
but this is their killer
experiment, the test
for all of them at once.
They present exactly
the same events.
The only difference is you
don't see A initially at rest
and starting to move.
OK?
You never get to see that.
There are screens on the
two ends of the display,
so all you see is that A enters
the display already in motion
and contacts B. So you have
no evidence as to whether A
is self-propelled
or not, but you
see the two objects interacting
otherwise in the same way.
That makes the effect
completely go away.
I think this is
logically a little
like the studies
with infants where
you show that the thing
is animate or not,
and it effects whether
they expect that there's
an agent there or not.
It suggests that infants
are representing A
as causing its own motion.
They're representing it
as causing B's motions,
so A is a better object
of imprinting than B is.
And all of this can
be abolished if A
isn't seen to have the
first causal property,
they're not
inferring the second.
So it's, again, an existence
proof kind of argument saying,
you can get this kind of system
working in an animal that
hasn't had prior visual
experiences in which they've
seen objects in motion or in
which they themselves have
been-- they haven't had any
other encounters with objects,
so they haven't been able
to move things around.
So that's one way of trying to
get at early representations.
Here's another way
that I hope Sommerville
will talk about
on Thursday night,
because she pioneered this
method with Amanda Woodward
and Amy Needham.
You can give a 3-month-old
infant, who otherwise wouldn't
be reaching for things
for another two months,
you can give them the
ability to pick up objects
by equipping them with mittens
that have Velcro on them
and presenting them
with Velcro objects.
So now they can
make things move.
And when you do that, you
see interesting changes
in their representations
of these events.
So an infant who has
played with an object
while wearing a sticky
mitten, who subsequently looks
at events in which another
person wearing that mitten
reaches for that object
or for another object,
now they look like a
5-month-old and represent
that reaching as goal-directed.
But on the other hand, if
they saw those same events
without the mittens,
they failed.
So that's saying that
the infant's own action
experience can elicit these
action representations.
And it raises, I think, all
sorts of interesting questions
about, do infants have
to learn one by one
what the properties
of agents are?
Or is it possible that
once these representations
of goal-directed
actions are elicited,
we'll see other knowledge
of agents already present?
So let me just give you
one finding that suggests
we might get the second.
This is a study that Amy Skerry
performed rather recently.
She was interested in
this representation
of efficient action
before babies
are able to reach for and
pick up objects themselves.
Do they already represent
the actions of agents
as directed to
goals efficiently?
Did they already expect that
agents will move efficiently
to achieve their goals?
So to get at that, she gave
infants, 3-month-old infants,
sticky mittens experience
with an object where
they got to pick up the
object and then showed them
events in one-- split them
into two different conditions,
and in both conditions,
they see events
in which a person moves on an
indirect path to an object.
In one of the series of events,
there's a barrier in the way,
so that motion is the best way
to get there, probably the only
obvious way to get there.
In the other case, the
barrier is in the display,
but it's out of the way, so
this is not an efficient action.
And then at test, the barrier
is gone in both conditions,
and the person either
moves efficiently or moves
inefficiently.
Now, in this control
condition, the baby
does not expect
efficient action.
But in the condition
where they previously
had the sticky mittens
experience, which presumably
told them that this is
actually the person's goal,
that they're attempting
to get there, once
they have that, what seems
to follow immediately
from that is this
efficiency, this principle
of efficient action,
right, that you'll
move to the goal on the
most direct path possible,
even though you've never
seen that direct path.
And even though
when the infant was
playing with the
object with the mittens
on and picking up objects for
the first time in his life,
there were no barriers present.
They never had to do
anything indirect.
They could always get
that object directly.
Yet they're expecting
direct action
only when they've seen efficient
action in another agent.
OK.
So in summary, it looks like
these abilities are all there
quite early.
They're unlearned,
at least some of them
are unlearned, in chicks.
And they can be
elicited before--
at least some of them can be
elicited before reaching--
develops in young infants.
But infants-- and this
is important, I think,
for what Alia's going
to be talking about--
infants' understanding
of agents is limited.
It's radically limited, just
like their understanding
of inanimate objects is.
And here are a few, I think,
really interesting limits.
Although infants are
sensitive to what's
perceptually
accessible to an agent,
they don't seem to represent
agents as seeing objects.
What do I mean by that?
Well, here's a experiment
with exactly the structure
of the Woodward
reaching experiment.
Two objects present, and
a person acts with respect
to one of them.
But instead of reaching
for one object,
she looks at one
of the two objects.
And now, you ask, after you
exchange the two objects'
positions, do babies
find that she's
doing something newer if she
looks at the other object?
Or do they find she's
doing something newer
if she looks in a
different direction
than she looked in before?
OK?
At 12 months, infants view
looking as object-directed,
by this measure.
Younger than 12
months, they do not.
They don't seem to view the
orientation of the person
as a look that's directed
to one of these two objects,
by that measure.
Now, the age at
which they succeeded,
this is also the
first age at which
infants start to show this
really interesting pattern
in their communication
with other people,
that Mike Tomasello has
written about a lot.
It's the first age
at which they'll
start to alternately
look at objects,
and look at another
person, and attempt
to engage their attention to
the object, by checking back
and forth between looks at the
person and looks at the object,
or by pointing to the object,
or by following another person's
point to an object.
All of that comes in at
the end of the first year.
It's not there earlier.
Younger infants, younger
than about 12 months of age,
don't even seem to expect
that if a person reaches
for one of two objects, they'll
tend to reach for the object
that they were looking at.
OK?
We thought for sure babies would
succeed at that task early.
They don't reliably
succeed at it
until 12 or even
14 months of age.
And finally, babies
attribute first order but not
second order goals to agents.
So if they see an
agent pull on a rake
and then reach for
an object, they
perceive the agent's goal
as the rake, not the object
that they're reaching for.
So very limited representations.
Also, as far as we know, none
of these are unique to humans.
I think this raised
all sorts of questions
that we might want to talk
about in the Q&A later.
What's the relationship between
infants' representations
of agents and their
representations of the things
that agents act on?
Clearly, these should be related
in some interesting ways.
Although, agents can do
things that objects can't do,
like move on their own,
and formulate goals,
and act on things that are
visually accessible to them.
Agents also are objects, right?
And we're subject to all
the constraints on objects.
We can't walk through walls.
If we want to make something
move, we have to contact it.
And babies are sensitive
to those constraints.
And I think this raises
all sorts of questions
that to date, research on
infants hasn't really answered.
Is there some hierarchy
of representations
where you've got all
objects, and then you've
got these especially talented
objects that are agents, right?
Or I think one way Tomer has put
it is maybe we're all agents,
but objects are just
really bad agents, right,
that can't do very much.
That's one possibility.
It's also possible
that these are just
separate systems
at the beginning,
and they have to get
linked together over time.
I think these are all
answerable questions.
I said that babies don't see
looking as directed to objects,
but they do from birth respond
in a pro-social way to looking
that's directed to them.
So an infant will
look longer at someone
whose eyes are directed
to them than someone
whose eyes are looking away.
That's true for human infants.
It's also true for
infant monkeys.
If a monkey is presented
with this display,
and they're over here,
they'll look longer than
if they're over here.
Right?
When they're here, it looks like
that guy is looking at them.
They also, human
and monkey infants
engage in eye-to-eye contact
with adults from birth.
They also, human infants
and monkey infants
tend to imitate the
gestures of other people,
interestingly, only when those
people are looking at them,
not when they close their eyes.
Then they'll imitate them as
you saw in those beautiful films
that Winrich showed
from the Ferrari group,
attentive to the person and
then trying to reproduce
the person's action.
This has been shown with baby
chimpanzees and baby monkeys
as well as with human
newborn infants.
And finally, I said infants
don't follow gaze to objects.
That's true, but it's also true
that if they see a person who's
looking directly
at them, and then
the person's gaze
shifts to the side,
they'll continue to
look at the person,
but their attention will
undergo a momentary shift
in the direction of the shift
of the other person's gaze.
OK?
So this has been shown
at two months of age
and also with newborn infants.
It's been shown with
photographs of real faces
and also with schematic faces.
The way to show that
attention is shifting
is to present infants with
an event that could never
happen in the real world.
You have an image of a face,
the eyes shift to the side,
either left or right, and
then the face disappears,
and a probe appears either
on the left or on the right.
They'll get to the
probe faster if it
appears on the side to which
the person shifted their gaze.
And nice control studies
show that it's not
just any kind of low level
motion in that direction that
gets them there.
So this could be a
sign of something
like infancy direct gaze.
And it engages something like
a state of engagement with
another person in which evidence
about the other person's state
of attention-- possibly also
emotion if the questionable
literature on empathy
emerging early is right--
this can be automatically
spread from one person
to a social partner.
So the hypothesis
is that infants
are finding other
potential social partners
from the beginning
of life, by looking
at things like gaze
direction, maybe also
infant-directed speech, as a
signal that someone else is
engaging with them, by
interpreting patterns
of imitation as a
communicative signal
that somebody is
tracking what they do,
and acting in kind with
them, and interpreting shifts
of attention as-- you're
responding to shifts
of attention by shifting
their own mental states
in the same direction.